in 2008 the online crowdfunding platform
IndieGoGo created a new way for
entrepreneurs artists and charities to
raise funds for their passion projects
anyone can go online and give money to
support the ventures they believe in the
first ever smartphone controlled paper
airplane in 2009 Kickstarter got into
the game and today new ventures get
launched everyday thanks to the
significant capital raised through these
crowdfunding platforms when you fund a
project on IndieGoGo you're getting what
we call a perk so for example if
someone's raising five or ten thousand
dollars to open up a new restaurant they
can actually offer a meal or the
opportunity to go to the opening night
party when the restaurant opens well
what if instead of free DVDs and tongue
scrapers for your pet dog bad breath is
one of the major concerns of dog owners
new companies could offer their funders
an equity stake in the business itself
hi I'm Simon Griffiths co-founder of
crickets and crafted so if that bug
killing salt on land its manufacturer in
the fortune 500 or that environmentally
sound toilet paper starts flying off the
shelves
those who backed it would see some money
I'm sitting down for what I believe in
and I'm not getting up until I've got
some toilet paper security regulations
dating back to the 1930s have made it
difficult for companies to trade equity
for cash it's illegal for you to go
online and fund your cousin's restaurant
in exchange for equity but two years ago
President Obama signed the u.s. Jobs Act
which is supposed to open venture
capital markets to the masses for the
first time ordinary Americans will be
able to go online and invest in
entrepreneurs that they believe in
Ringelmann says it's all about allowing
regular people to make investments based
on their direct knowledge of specific
industries there's a whole world of
people that know what they know
and they don't have the ability to
invest in what they know so maybe if you
know how to build engines why shouldn't
you have the ability to invest in the
next cool type of oil that makes engines
more efficient equity crowdfunding is
going to give Main Street investors the
same opportunities that Wall Street has
had for ever but will Washington
actually allow this new approach to work
it took a full year and a half after the
passage of the US jobs act for the
Securities and Exchange Commission to
release a 585 page document laying out
how will regulate equity crowdfunding
among other things companies that want
to raise money on platforms like
IndieGoGo will have to produce financial
statements provide a narrative
discussion of financial results and file
annual reports with the SEC compliance
costs could chase away lots of promising
ventures and the world of open
information why do we need the SEC
getting in the way in the first place a
finance will fundamentally be different
going forward because the Internet is
making things transparent I think if the
SEC can just stay open and allow the
platform's to experiment I think we'll
get there
Oh